ils étaient une centaine d'agents du
conseil départemental des yvelines des
travailleurs sociaux manifestantes
devant l'hôtel du département ce mardi
19 mars à l'appel de la cgt de la
fédération autonome de la fonction
publique territoriale
leurs principales revendications la
baisse des moyens budgétaires alloués au
secteur de l'action sociale des yvelines
le constat c'est qu'en fait on nous
alourdir la charge de travail en créant
de nouvelles missions des nouvelles
missions avec lesquels on pourrait être
d'accord on réorganise l'accueil on
réorganise l'enfance la santé
l'insertion et le travail social
mais à chaque fois c'est sans moyens et
avec des missions complémentaires comme
on peut pas mener la même qualité de
service et quand on est aux prises avec
des pertes des familles qui sont
surendettés en procédure d'expulsion de
la violence conjugale
on a une charge mentale lourd à absorber
pour mener à bien son travail et on se
dit bon bah maintenant j'ai plus que 20
minutes pour gérer ce que je faisais en
1h30 quoi assistant social éducateurs
spécialisés ou encore conseillers en
économie sociale et familiale les postes
occupés par ces agents dans les centres
de protection maternelle et infantile ou
de planification d'éducation familiale
leur mission accompagner les publics en
difficulté
nous demandons aux départements
davantage de moyens
changer sa politique de réduction des
effectifs de réductions budgétaires
en considérant que la priorité d'une
collectivité départementale doit être de
consacrer son effort et notamment son
effort financier à destination des
familles les plus en difficulté
sollicité le conseil départemental n'a
pas donné suite à notre demande
d'interview